[Applause]
[Music]
recently we've published a lot of videos
about
venezuela and the terrible political
situation that that country is facing
we've told you how they've got to this
point the basic characteristics of this
narco dictatorship and how the
revolution involved the bolivarian
revolution has condemned most
venezuelans to poverty even causing one
of the
greatest exoduses in history venezuelan
refugees now number 3.4 million
humanitarian implications massive u.n
warrants
however while events are rushing ahead
of warp speed with this man juan guido
leading a firm opposition against the
maduro regime we thought that we needed
to make a general review of a
fundamental issue
[Music]
who are nicholas maduro's main allies
who are the players that continue
despite
everything to support this regime and
why what
are their interests
it may seem incredible given the current
circumstances but the chavez regime
continues to have some
very formidable allies and listen up
because these are the four most
influential partners the four
strongest allies that the venezuelan
regime still has
fourth today for you tomorrow for me
2010 saw the beginning of a beautiful
relationship or perhaps it would be more
accurate to call it
a hateful fellowship leave that up to
you to decide that year nicholas maduro
traveled to turkey as venezuela's
chancellor there he met current turkish
president taip erdogan
these are two politicians who feel
attacked by the west
and the relationship is mainly based on
emotions erdogan
doesn't forget that maduro was one of
the first leaders who supported him
during the attempted coup
of july 15 2016. now turkey is returning
the support they
received met met oscon center for global
policy
of washington so we can understand this
better the relationship
goes a little something like this hey
look it turns out the rest of the world
has it in for us they say that we're
authoritarian as if
bringing about order was such a bad
thing they say we don't respect
freedom of the press either so how about
if you support me
and i'll support you these populist and
authoritarian leaders are seeking to
develop
man-to-man relations rather than relying
on institutions bureaucracies or rules
map met oscon the fact is that since the
turkish coup d'etat took place or as is
suspected the auto coup d'etat
trade between both countries has
multiplied 13
fold in 2018 alone export from venezuela
to turkey surpassed a billion dollars
and no this wasn't industrial or even
agricultural products
not at all i'm talking about the last
source of foreign currency with which
the venezuela regime has attempted to
stay alive
talking about gold
turkey has become a satellite
headquarters for refining
certifying and distributing venezuelan
gold
[Music]
it is the perfect laundry so to speak
allowing nicholas maduro's government to
continue to obtain foreign currency
this is becoming more and more
complicated however especially after the
collapse that the oil industry has been
experiencing
venezuela oil exports slumped to a
28-year low
[Music]
apparently the agreement that venezuela
and turkey signed would be allowing
caracas to
evade united states sanctions
mysterious turkish firm helped maduro
move 900 million in gold
in the last few months sightings of
private russian and turkish jets have
been
frequent at caracas airport some of them
by the way are owned by
cine a mining company that is very close
with the president of turkey well what
is suspected is that these planes are
arriving in caracas to get gold from the
country
in a rather shady way and i'm sure you
can probably guess where a lot of that
gold is gonna end up
but relationships they go beyond that in
december of 2018
not all that long ago erigan starred in
the first visit of a turkish head of
state to venezuela during this
trip commercial agreements with a value
of more than 5 billion were signed and
the creation of joint ventures for
exploration and exploitation of coal
gold and oil were also announced
for example it's highly significant that
the turkish food industry provides about
70 of the food
that the venezuelan government
distributes under the clap program
these are food bags that are delivered
to families monthly as a
means to gain some sort of popular
support
[Music]
third what about my things
it's well known that throughout the
bolivarian revolution cuba's role
was extremely significant
[Music]
cuba first supplied hugo chavez and then
nicolas maduro with paramilitary forces
protection and intelligence teams
practically everything that the
venezuelan bigwigs needed to consolidate
their power
venezuela is nine times larger than cuba
and has
three times its population and its
economy is four times larger
the country is home to the world's
largest oil reserves
however some crucial functions of the
venezuelan state
have been delegated to cuban officials
or are directly controlled by havana
maduro is not a venezuelan patriot
he is a cuban puppet that's what he is
it may be controversial to say but cuba
has basically become a supermarket
of terror for all dictators according to
the secretary general of the
organization of american states louis
almagro there are between
twenty one thousand and forty six
thousand cubans in venezuela
rubio cuban agents direct repression in
urina venezuela
cuba is responsible for repression and
torture in venezuela
luis almagro secretary general of the
oas
of course none of this has come for free
you see in exchange for supplying
doctors and paramilitary forces cuba has
received a lot of oil in more than
advantageous conditions from the
venezuelan government in recent years in
fact during the bolivarian revolution
the cuban economy was very dependent on
venezuela although
not quite as much as the soviet union
[Music]
however as things continue to progress
and although they still seem to be
playing a key role in the repression
today the island simply
doesn't have enough economic resources
to keep the narco
chavez regime on its feet what i mean is
that in the future cuba's biggest role
may be only to give refuge to nicolas
maduro and his cronies as long as the
dea
doesn't capture them first
second business is business
if you follow this channel regularly you
may know this well we've focused
a lot on the caracas beijing
relationship i know this isn't an
ideological issue
it was is and probably will be with or
without maduro a pure
matter of business oil is the most
fundamental reason
why china and venezuela joined powers
china needed a lot of oil and venezuela
had it
the relationship flourished since then
and both built ties based on
oil financing agreements matt farshin
carnegie shingua center for global
policy you see the first oil loan
agreements between china and venezuela
date back to 2007
for hugo chavez's venezuela these
agreements meant fresh
constant and sound cash flow for his
revolution for china on the other hand
gaining access to the latin american
country's huge
energy resources was something that the
chinese economy needed at all costs
their oil consumption rates increased
year after year and they needed to
secure their supply
[Music]
and we are talking about small numbers
here
according to data from the center for
inter-american studies and boston
university between 2007 and 2018
china lent the latin american country
almost 70 billion
today the debt seems to surpass 20
billion and to be fair we
must say that maduro he hasn't exactly
been a
good payer
beijing trusted that the venezuelan
authorities would be able to do
something productive with all of the
money that they'd put on the table at
the very least
invest enough to maintain oil production
levels beijing never imagined that the
venezuelan government would be
quite so disastrous and so for the
chinese all of this is just
fundamentally a matter of
business leading to incidents like this
china sues venezuela's oil company over
unpaid bills
in spite of everything beijing suspects
that their agreements could be
endangered if there's a government
change which could mean
not charging part of the debt that
venezuela has to pay in
oil or even losing the privileged access
that they are getting from venezuela's
huge reserves
it is precisely for this reason that one
of president juan cuado's objectives
seems to be to assure the chinese that
rather happens the past
agreements will be respected
china talks with venezuela opposition to
protect investments
no matter how the situation evolves
china venezuela cooperation
should not be undermined gengxuang
foreign ministry spokesman of the
people's republic of china
in any case if you want to learn more
about this relationship do not
miss this video and finally we get to
the last
ally and what may be nicholas maduro's
last hope
[Music]
first a spearhead against the west
nowadays vladimir putin's russia is the
biggest international supporter that
nicolas maduro's regime has
[Music]
in the last two decades russian
companies have secured important
military contract
and since 2015 many rights to some of
the most significant oil and gas fields
in venezuela
and they have achieved all of this at
bargain prices want an example
well take a look at this
[Music]
in exchange for a desperate 1.5 billion
rescue the venezuelan government has set
49.9 percent of its stake in citgo
pdvsa's crown jewel an oil company that
operates in the united states where it
owns three refineries a huge gas
pipeline network and almost 6 000
service stations as warranty if pdvsa
doesn't pay the 1.5 billion
they owe to rosneft and gazprom
venezuela could be forced to sell what
is today
its most valuable industrial asset at a
very low price
all for just 1.5 billion dollars
[Music]
and it's at this point we really have to
point out that 1.5 billion dollars for
half of
citgo is almost a joke with that we can
say well
welcome to maduro's desperation sale
[Music]
the point is folks that russia has
become the venezuelan government's
number one supplier of weapons
military equipment and instruments of
repression we seek a peaceful transition
of power
but all options are open
missiles tanks planes in recent years
the bolivarian government has spent a
lot of money on russian equipment
for putin venezuela has meant a huge
amount of business for his military
industry which is
incredibly important in russia but also
now putin sees it as an opportunity to
continue
poking the west's eye while he increases
his control
over some of the planet's largest energy
reserves
anyway folks these are the four most
important allies on which nicolas
maduro's narco dictatorship still
counts also on the list would be
countries like bolivia nicaragua and
belarus but they have a much smaller
influence globally as it stands the
bolivarian government will do anything
it can to
secure russia china and turkeys they
already have cubase
full expressed and firm support even if
they have to sell
what little remains in venezuela however
the political weakness
and the chaos that the chevez government
has created is so
extreme that this may no longer be
enough to bargain with
basically with this video we wanted to
better explain who continues to support
this train wreck of a regime but now
it's your turn do you think that maduro
will manage to stay in power
at least for what remains of 2019. i'll
leave your answer in the comments below
as well as in this survey and i really
hope you enjoyed this video please do
hit that like button if you did and
don't forget to subscribe for brand new
videos
also don't forget to check out our
friends at the reconsider media podcast
who provided the vocals in this episode
that were not mine also this channel
it's possible because of patreon and our
patrons on that platform please consider
joining them and supporting our mission
of providing independent political
coverage
and as always i'll see you in the next
video maduro is not a venezuelan patriot
he is a cuban puppet that's what he is
we seek a peaceful transition of power
but all options are over